so we're continuing our uh discovery for
lack of a better term of
who did what who knew what who tried
what in the lead-up to the november of
2020 election in the period between the
november election and the january 6
riots and then after the january 6 riots
to try to cover up
what was done tried said and attempted
during that previous period of time and
a lot of the stuff we're learning we're
learning
thanks to the work of this house select
committee investigating the january six
riots in the next segment
uh we're going to have some uh
incredible revelations from republic
republican congresswoman liz cheney but
before we get to that
we are now getting a list of documents
from the house committee
we don't yet or won't have
all of the content of each of these uh
documents
but what we know so far is i mean
chilling and disturbing is probably an
understatement listen to this
chilling trump letter
calling for seizure of election material
revealed in log to january 6th probers
the letter was created a day before
trump discussed naming conspiracy
theorist sidney powell special counsel
to probe baseless election fraud claims
the document in question and you can
find this is there's a pdf and i'm
putting it up on the screen you can find
this this is publicly available
mixed in with a whole bunch of other
documents which may or may not be
interesting to you there is an item
called draft potus letter meaning a
draft letter from trump
uh and it says it is described as draft
letter from potus to seize evidence in
the interest of national security for
the 2020 elections
now
there are
a few interpretations of what this
could be and they're all absolutely
terrifying let's go back to this
huffington post article which outlines a
bunch of it the log along with a trove
of documents was provided last week they
were handed over by trump ally bernie
carrick former nypd commissioner and
confidant of rudy giuliani carrick was a
key advisor to trump's legal team trying
to cook up a narrative of fraud in the
presidential election that joe biden won
besides the documents carrick turned
over he also offered a log of documents
he refused to provide including the
trump letter among the documents
withheld is one described as draft
letter from potus to seize evidence in
the interest of national security in the
2020 election
though trump ultimately didn't take
action to seize election materials such
a letter could be a key piece of
information in the investigation into
trump's strategy to undermine a
legitimate election authorities have
found no evidence of fraud the letter
was created december 18th that's the day
before he met with general flynn and
others to try to figure out what to do
trump also discussed naming far-right
attorney conspiracy theorist sidney
powell a special counsel he ultimately
didn't do that
flynn had already suggested trump could
invoke martial law to seize control of
the election remember
this is the guy
who
wanted to review voter registrations
nationally right that's one idea trump
floated i believe it was in advance of
the midterms um this is not someone who
considers
sacred
uh information related to people's uh
actual voting and what it means sees
information is not even exactly clear
but it's extraordinarily authoritarian
you know we talked earlier all of these
right-wingers say
when twitter banned marjorie taylor
green for kova disinformation when
twitter banned dr robert malone for
covet disinformation that's
authoritarian fascism no it's not it's a
private business enforcing terms of
service in a completely legal way on the
other hand when a sitting president
drafts a letter saying let's seize
election materials which could be
mail-in ballots
it could be
voting machines it could be all sorts of
different things let's seize it and try
to use it to steal the election which
was of course the goal
that in and of itself deserves an
investigation that is the authoritarian
nightmare that these right-wingers say
twitter is actually doing when we now
understand the context of all of this
which was trying to do an insurrectious
coup
what exactly
did trump and his legal team plan on
doing with the voting data
even the guy trump put in charge
remember that whole committee that but
you might have forgotten about it
because it found nothing but i think it
was called the voter integrity
commission or committee or something he
put that guy uh kris kobach the kansas
secretary of state in charge of it um it
found nothing
even he wasn't willing to seize the
voter information back during that
period or wasn't willing
maybe just realized it wouldn't work
right
and as i was
reading all of this over the weekend i
don't know how many of you saw the
recent film don't look up with leonardo
dicaprio and jennifer lawrence and a
bunch of other actors
it feels much more like a documentary
than satire the more we read about what
this administration was doing uh towards
uh towards the very end the honestly the
the most
so there may be a spoiler here there may
be a spoiler there may be a spoiler
about the the film don't look up
the most unrealistic part of don't look
up
was that some people actually changed
their minds once they saw the comet with
their own eyes
trumpists would have claimed even
looking at the comment you can't believe
that you can only believe what trump
says it must be a soros-founded
projection that looks like a comment
meant to scare us into accepting
government control or whatever i mean
that's how weaponized this
disinformation has become and as we
learn about all of the things they
almost tried uh it makes it even more
urgent that we put in safeguards so that
they can't even get this going in uh
2024 and we've talked about that earlier
we're going to talk about it again
the only streaming service that
specializes in documentaries is
curiosity stream and you can get
curiosity stream one of our sponsors for
just 15 bucks a year when you use my
link below this will give you access to
the world's best selection of
documentary films there's always
so many that you can't get on netflix
hulu or amazon i just finished watching
a tremendous film the ceo
of sinaloa sinaloa a region of mexico
it's about el chapo fascinating
fascinating curiosity stream is a
must-have
if you love documentaries they always
have the best and newest titles they're
always adding new things to the library
and you can watch on all of your devices
they've got documentaries on every topic
you can imagine curiosity stream is
giving my audience 25 office
subscription making it just 15 bucks a
month go to curiositystream.com
pacman the link is down below